[Musique]
le jardin de l'état s'est transformé en
un lieu magique à l'occasion des fêtes
de noël
depuis huit ans le département organise
au bonheur des enfants avec toujours la
même envie de voir les étoiles dans les
yeux des petits comme des grands
au bonheur des enfants cette année le
thème c'est quand la nature s'en mêle
donc on a voulu recréer déjà toujours là
surprise il y a énormément d'ateliers
cette année des ateliers tenus par nos
services services du département
l'idée c'est vraiment que les enfants
comme les parents assistent participent
créer quelque chose et repartent avec
leur création voilà le président du
département en profiter de l'occasion
pour souhaiter ses voeux à l'ensemble
des lignes
je voudrais d'abord dire à mes
compatriotes réunionnais bonne fête de
la liberté puisque le 20 décembre c'est
la commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
alors bonne fête de la liberté à tout et
puis après
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année puisqu'il ya
noël et le jour de l'an c'est l'occasion
de se retrouver en famille avec les amis
pour faire la fête
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année et pour 2020
tous mes voeux vous accompagne le voeux
de bonheur de santé de prospérité mais
surtout la santé mam aux ateliers
structures gonflables ou encore tunnel
magique la féerie de noël est bel et
bien lancée
c'est super j'ai fait ça le manège qui
[Musique]
s'est très très bien
ça fait plusieurs années que je viens
avec mes petits enfants et chaque année
je trouve ça vraiment très agréable très
bien je crois que les enfants apprécient
beau le spectacle était merveilleux je
pense revenir demain j'espère qu'il aura
pas trop de monde c'est une bouteille
problème mais vraiment on passe de bons
moments au bonheur des enfants se
poursuivra jusqu'au dimanche 22 décembre
chaque soir à 19h30 les familles
pourront profiter du spectacle
pyrotechnique suivi du feu d'artifice
[Musique]